l'aéroport d'hanoï le 21 janvier
nous sommes deux jours avant le premier
cas recensé dans le pays
et pourtant des caméras thermiques
contrôle déjà la température des
passagers
le symbole d'une prise de conscience
rapide des autorités vietnamiennes à la
mi janvier
dès les premiers cas en chine un comité
de gestion de crise a vu le jour
réunissant ministère médecins et
scientifiques afin d'anticiper
l'expansion du comité 19 une
anticipation qui se traduit par la
fermeture rapide du trafic aérien vers
la chine et des 1300 kilomètres de leur
frontière commune avec pékin
malgré les réticences des autorités
chinoises personnel de soins retraités
et étudiants en médecine sont
réquisitionnés la production de masques
et prioriser et le gouvernement interdit
la réouverture des écoles dès le 13
février après les vacances du têt
le nouvel an vietnamien le même jour le
vietnam devient d'ailleurs le premier
pays hors chine a imposé une quarantaine
pendant 21 jours
dix mille personnes d'une zone
résidentielle du nord d'hanoï sont
soumises au confinement après la
découverte de cas parmi des travailleurs
revenant de one nous avons installé un
checkpoint à la demande des autorités
nous serons ici en permanence pour
empêcher les gens de sortir en douce
probablement et propager la maladie car
plutôt que de se lancer dans des tests
de masse trop coûteux pour un pays au
faible revenu par habitant
les autorités se sont davantage
concentrées sur l' isolement des
personnes infectées et la recherche de
tous leurs contacts
une surveillance étroite de la
population rendue possible par une
police et un parti communiste
omniprésent dans la société vietnamienne
mais aussi grâce à une population très
respectueuse des consignes invités à
dénoncer publiquement les individus
fautifs emprisonné immédiatement malgré
cela le 1er avril le gouvernement
instaurer un plan d'isolement social
pour 15 jours avec port du masque
obligatoire recommandation de ne pas
sortir de chez soi sauf pour aller
travailler et interdiction de
rassemblement
je pense que la mesure d'isolement
social est nécessaire en ce moment pour
encourager les gens à ne pas sortir pour
des grands rassemblements en particulier
à des fins inutiles comme les loisirs ou
les repas au restaurant
je ne pense pas qu'en ce moment on ait
besoin d'un confinement de la ville ou
du pays tout entier
vendredi dernier les autorités danoises
ont assoupli ce plan tout en le
prolongeant d'une semaine dans certaines
régions jugées à risque un allègement
progressif
si certains commerces ont rouvert ce
n'est pas le cas des bars et restaurants
et le port du masque demeure lui
toujours obligatoire